mein thema heute abend sind die der
sanktionen meine these ist die
sanktionen bestraft auf und selbst der
krieg ist furchtbar wir müssen russland
stoppen für die freiheit einstehen aber
jede sanktion für russland da müssen wir
auch ehrlich sein schadet uns in
deutschland ebenfalls nicht immer im
selben ausmaß aber sie schadet die
wirtschaftlichen verflechtungen sind
einfach zu groß nicht nur beim thema
energie wenn wir die 27 milliarden euro
exporte von deutschland nach russland
sanktionieren leiden darunter unsere
unternehmen denen diese umsätze
wegfallen die zahl von 27 milliarden
scheint abstrakt groß und anonym aber
lassen sie es mich einmal anders
ausdrücken
2700 unternehmen also fast zehn
unternehmen je landkreis den jeweils und
jedes jahr ein zehn millionen auftrag
abhanden kommt dass es für viele
mittelständler existenzgefährdend und
führt unweigerlich zu kurzarbeit
entlassungen im schlimmeren
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen sind
natürlich das kleinere übel im vergleich
zu kriegerischen handlungen aber wir
dürfen bei aller euphorie für immer
härtere sanktionen auch nicht vergessen
dass für jede bestrafung russland wir
uns auch selber bestrafen die wirtschaft
ist der motor unseres landes und es muss
uns alarmieren dass die erste
unternehmen aufgrund der steigenden
energiepreise produktionsanlagen
ausstellen die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
unserer industrie es gefährdet und die
lage ist dramatisch die außenministerin
der berbalk hat heute hier bei bild
gesagt zitat nur sanktionen werden den
krieg nicht stoppen sollen wir müssen
alle möglichen kanäle nutzen paul
außerhalb der sanktion welche kanäle
können wir noch nutzen
ich glaube dass tatsächlich die
sanktionen das entscheidende sind
überhaupt dafür zu sorgen dass wladimir
putin bereit sein wird über bestimmte
dinge zu sprechen und ich glaube dass
die sanktionen das einzige mittel sind
am ende auch dafür zu sorgen dass die
russische bevölkerung merkt was der
russische präsident dort tut denn ich
gebe wolfgang ischinger vollkommen recht
auch wenn man sich anschaut wie groß die
anzahl derjenigen ist die noch immer
hinter ihrem präsidenten stehen und wir
tatsächlich hierdurch
eine babbel in berlin und überall
vielleicht eine falsche wahrnehmung
dessen haben
das massen fernsehen dort sorgt für
perfekte grausame propaganda also ich
habe gerade erst wieder gesehen wie dort
ukrainische häftlinge vorgeführt wurden
die dann all das wiederholt haben was
putin in seiner rede gesagt hat dass
hier in der ukraine über nazis sind das
ist alles ganz schlimm ist dass die
nato-staaten mit krieg führen also
erschafft dieses konstrukt und ich finde
dass deshalb auch so deprimierend weil
wir eigentlich mal 2010 gedacht haben
mensch durch facebook twitter durch
social media wird das alles viel viel
freier und diktatoren und diktaturen
haben keine chance mehr so das land
jetzt von dem thema sanktionen wieder
etwas ab aber tatsächlich ist es so ich
glaube man kann nicht so einfach sagen
es ist nur putin und
der rest sozusagen russland kann nichts
dafür nein die haben diesen mann gewählt
die unterstützen ihn noch immer und die
müssen jetzt verstehen dass das was sie
dort tun an verbrecherischen krieg zu
führen einen krieg zu führen der kinder
sterben lässt frauen sterben lässt der
städte in schutt und asche legt dass das
massivste konsequenzen hat
einschneidendste konsequenzen hat und
aus meiner sicht können die sanktionen
gar nicht scharf genug paul es geht mir
bei meiner these überhaupt nicht darum
dass ich sage wir dürfen müssen jetzt
russland schützen und sollten deswegen
keine sanktion machen sondern es geht um
die welt samt wenn deutschland diese
sanktion umsetzt ja und damit auch mit
blick auf poel zum beispiel dann kann
russland ja weiter nach china verkaufen
und dadurch dass die preise immer mehr
steigen wird auch der verlust in
russland kompensiert meine einzige frage
ist dementsprechend wie viel wären
unsere sanktionen denn auch mit mit
blick auf die rolle chinas überhaupt
nutzen und können wir mit den sanktionen
wirklich diesen krieg beenden wenn man
sieht dass russland kompensieren kann
mit china und all die anderen faktoren
einbegriffen
ich glaube das sollte uns einfach
erstmal gar nicht interessieren weil
daran können wir nichts ändern was china
macht wir können natürlich versuchen
einfluss auf china zu nehmen durch
diplomaten diplomatische kanäle und die
deutsche wirtschaft ist dort auch
wichtig also all das können wir tun aber
zunächst einmal müssen wir doch unsere
unserer eigenen wertesystem folgen wir
müssen doch unserer moral folgen und
sagen das was hier passiert das
akzeptieren wir nicht und das wird
bestraft und das muss so solche
konsequenzen haben solch einschneidenden
konsequenzen haben dass das lade mir
putin merkt und wenn er es nicht merken
dann sein umfeld also die debatte sie
sehe ich nicht
gerne hersteller gerne
sehen würde gerne ja ich würde gerne
zwei punkte machen erstens
sanktionen sind nie ein allheilmittel
sanktionen haben immer die medikamente
auch nebenwirkungen und bin deswegen
muss man den beipackzettel genau liest
sie haben das ja gerade betreibt und 1
um zwei
sanktionen gegen russland
müssen wir so gestalten dass er normale
russe die normale russinnen nicht das
gefühl bekommt die wollen mich bestrafen
wir müssen die sanktionen so
maßschneidern dass sie die russische
elite die führungsschicht die
geheimdienste die kreise um putin
wenigen die die inhaber der macht sind
wenn ich wenn sie mir eine minute und
einer bibliothek geben erzähle ich noch
eine kleine anekdote die dazu passen als
angela merkel als neue bundeskanzlerin
anfang 2006 nach washington und ihr
erstes gespräch als deutsche
bundeskanzlerin mit george bush sprach
fragte der sie was halten sie
angela sagte er was halten sie denn
eigentlich von sanktionen gegen teheran
damals ging es um diese frage und
baumberg und sagte wissen sie mit
installationen ist das so eine sache
als ich in der ddr aufwuchs war meine
familie war mein vater man die eltern
eigentlich eher gegner des
kommunistischen systems in moskau und
wollten sich durchaus wenn da aus
washington dann mal sanktionen gegen
die damalige kommunistische führung in
der sowjetunion ergriffen wurden wenn
aber diese sanktionen dazu führten dass
wir in der in mecklenburg vorpommern da
in ihrer heimatstadt
plötzlich keine orangen oder bananen
mehr bekamen dann dachten wir wieso
werden nicht bestraft doch gar nichts
gemacht das ist genau der zentrale punkt
können wir die sanktionen so gestalten
dass der normale busse weiß das gilt der
führung die hat hier verbrecherische
gewalttaten verübt das gilt aber nicht
uns die russen die russen sind nämlich
eigentlich unsere großen nachbarn und
freunde und diesel beziehung sollten wir
natürlich langfristig pflegen und
erhalten es geht um grund ihn und seine
crew ließ und es geht nicht um eine
feindschaft mit russland
naja ich glaube dass das dass das
natürlich um ihr wort zu nehmen
maßgeschneidert ist es so zu machen aber
ich denke es doch danach eine kleine
ergänzung zu machen oder nichts wenn wir
jetzt also leere supermarktregale sehen
sehen wir ja schon dass es nicht
funktioniert hat das maß zu schneidern
denn die leere supermarktregale werden
bedeuten dass die russische propaganda
sagt da könnte man sehen was der böse
westen mit euch macht jetzt wollen sie
verhungern lassen dann ist diese
gedankliche übertragung nee das ist ja
eine sanktion der regierung gegenüber
und deshalb müssen können wir jetzt
nichts mehr einkaufen das würde ist
schon viel verlangt ich will aber auch
noch etwas ergänzen was mir in letzter
zeit schwer fällt aber es muss immer mal
gesagt werden
natürlich haben sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr viele
russen wladimir putin gewählt und die
können jetzt nicht sagen wir haben mit
dem krieg nichts zu tun das können sie
nicht sagen also die zwar ist es eine
sagen wir mal
perverse form sein staatsoberhaupt zu
wählen wie das in russland funktioniert
es gibt ja wenn ich es richtig sehe
wenig wirkliche alternativen aber man
kann ja nicht sagen putin war mein
geliebter präsident und jetzt macht er
aber er hat jetzt das kriegführen nicht
erst vorgestern erfunden sondern hat
sich ja schon ein teil der ukraine
vorher einverleibt also alle dienen
danach noch mal gewählt haben haben auch
gewählt den expansionsdrang und putin
und deshalb finde ich es auch einen
gedanken wert ob man nicht auch das ein
bisschen mit sanktioniert
paar möchtest du noch was entgegnen du
hast unsere debatte gehört ich hoffe ja
immer ist die verbindung genannt zu dir
immer weitergeht ich hatte angst weil
das irgendwie gekappt will plötzlich
aber du hast alles gern möchte noch was
er wieder an
nein ich bin da tatsächlich eher auf der
seite von claus strunz denn ich glaube
auch dass es nicht funktionieren wird zu
sagen wir sanktionieren ausschließlich
oder machen diese zielgerichteten
sanktionen gegen die putin kreise die
werden trotzdem ihren weg finden die
idee müsste ja sein oder der hintergrund
bei dem was putin dort gerade macht und
wie er vorgeht dass wir ein interesse
daran haben dass menschen auf die straße
gehen und verstehen was dieser präsident
orth und
natürlich kann man auch das für naiv
verhalten weil sicherlich bleibt mir
putin es schaffen wird dann ihre not dem
westen zuzuschreiben da hat singer
dennoch recht aber ich glaube dass die
situation mittlerweile eine solch
dramatische ist dass wir nicht sagen
können okay oligarch xy dafür sich mehr
nach europa reisen und seine villa
konfiszieren wir und seine bankkonten in
der schweiz und dann war es das glaube
da kommen wir nicht mehr weiter ich hab
noch ein punkt der mir wichtig ist weil
er uns alle betrifft jetzt zur
diskussion neigen ja manchmal dazu dass
man immer sagt was die anderen machen
sollen sanktionen und das war ja wenn
ich es richtig verstanden lena auch den
punkt treffen uns auch hart und wir
bestrafen uns selber ich finde man muss
schon einmal die übersetzungsleistung
leisten auch in so einem forum zu sagen
wenn wir uns als bundesrepublik an einer
sanktion gegen russland beteiligen wird
jeden einzelnen von uns das was kosten
also wer jetzt sagt sanktionen sind
richtig muss auch sagen und ich bin auch
mit 10 100 1000 10.000 euro dabei damit
meine ich keine spenden damit meine ich
sozusagen weniger ausgeben für energie
damit meine ich
frieren für den frieden statt
krieg führen für den frieden wir können
nicht sagen sanktionen sind irgendwie
sowas was die da beim urinieren seinen
arbeitslosigkeit von der hand gehen
können nicht sagen geschehen ist sind
irgendwas was das so politische apparate
irgendwie verhängen und dann
funktionieren die vielleicht sondern
eine sanktion ist eine gemeinsame
willenserklärung des westens selber auch
verzicht zu leisten für das höhere gut
um dass es da in dem konflikt geht und
ich glaube das muss auch erst noch durch
dringlich will 1 ergänzen letztes ich
habe manchmal das gefühl dass diese
große welle der hilfsbereitschaft sich
jetzt für flüchtlinge zu engagieren auch
was damit zu tun hat dass menschen
zeigen wollen das ist mein beitrag ein
ganz konkreter beitrag ich nehme
jemanden auf und setzen damit ein
zeichen putin du kannst die menschen
vertreiben aber sie werden nie heimatlos
weil ich gebe ihnen eine neue jedenfalls
auf zeit das ist stärker und vielleicht
müssen wir noch sehr viel mehr auf diese
symbolik setzen